malgré l'inquiétude les annulations et
des autorisations le salon livres au
coeur d'orléans a pu se tenir dans les
immenses salles des serres du jardin des
plantes deux jours de rencontres
littéraires en forme de retrouvailles la
période là
peut-être plus propice finalement
à l'évasion quelque part dans la lecture
raconter des histoires j'étais pas les
mensonges libre et c'est vrai que j'aime
beaucoup faire sa part rencontrer des
auteurs
on a la chance que ça se produise sur
orléans de voir qui a la jeunesse qui
qui oeuvrent pour pour la littérature
pour les bandes dessinées etc
et j'aime rencontrer j'aime ce contact
avec ses hôtes rc éditeurs c'est
passionnant habitué de ce salon du livre
les petites maisons d'éditions
régionales avaient à coeur de montrer
leur bonne santé malgré la crise qui n'a
pas épargné ce secteur en adaptation
subventions et obstination les éditeurs
régionaux étaient bien là annulation
salon annulation dédicaces
par contre comme on avait le numérique
on a eu l'idée commence avec les gens à
les lire beaucoup plus chez eux de faire
une
une promotion sur nos livres pour
pouvoir les attirer un peu plus vers
notre jean et du coup permis de
compenser en partie les pertes
de vente au moment de la sortie de
l'album je n'aspire à et bien
nous n'avons pas pu en fait faire toutes
les animations qui était prévu nous
avons dû les reporter à une date
ultérieure qu'on ne connaissait pas et
donc sa logique et les ventes
l'existence même de cette troisième
édition de livres au coeur est un succès
les gens qui sont là pour vendre ils
sont quand même content parce qu'il ya
moins de monde il ya moins de tourisme
mais il ya les passionnés elle ceux qui
aiment lire
ils achètent toujours des lieux pour la
suite c'est l'incertitude et la crainte
de ne plus avoir de rencontres
littéraires organisées cette année